I'm micron and my favorite movie is
ordinary people I remember that ordinary
people came out New Year's a day 1980 I
didn't know what ordinary people was
gonna be but Mary Tyler Moore was in it
that was enough reason to see it she was
America's Sweetheart it was set in
Chicago mothers don't hate their son
that what he told you ordinary people's
about a family which I would not have
called ordinary a lake forest family
it's interesting that the reviewers all
called them upper middle class upper
middle class or rich the time Lake
Forest was a place where you thought
that everybody was perfect and while I
grew up 35 minutes from there it was a
world away from there it was a lesson
involved they don't presume and what
goes on in the wealthiest of households
can often be a struggle the ultimate
seen that movie was tell you about the
relationship is she doesn't want to take
a picture with him in front of the
christmas tree on Christmas Day no idea
what let's get the three men in there
and I'll take a picture of you Donald
Sutherland her husband is trying and you
just take just do it this time and she
just won't do it give me the capital I
didn't get it get there come on give me
the and at this moment you know there's
a problem I got a picture of the two of
years oh hang on a sec you're the
goddamn camera the first reaction of a
theater full of people back then is oh
my god I can't believe he did this and
the second reaction is good she deserved
it she had to come in I'm not afraid of
the sad story the greatest stories I've
written in the greatest stories I've
seen usually have a profound loser the
winner was always there to talk to
another day the loser is a story that
actually I think more people identify
with but dine It was as if you buried
all your love with him and I don't
understand that this is not off this not
uplifting movie it's movie that explored
relationships at a level which 21 years
old I hadn't
and it makes you thank my god this is no
not everything is easy
I'm Mike LaVon and I love movies love
them
you